Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Emporium.
Now I wanted to warn you guys
before we get into this;
this game apparently covers themes of
suicide, and maybe even darker subjects.
So, I just wanted to warn you guys
before getting into it, because
this will probably get dark,
and it will probably get sad.
So, I don't what to expect about it,
because, apparently, it's some sort of artistic
look at it-
"Analogies for personhood, for the self,
for consciousness, exert great power on our thinking,
and to think of consciousness as a locked chamber,
to think of the contents of that chamber as perception
that will thus seem *ilu-e- ineloostibly private,
to think of our experiencing of the world as hidden,
but hidden inwardly."
*ineluctably?
ineluctably private.
I have never heard of that word.
I have a pretty extensive vocabulary,
but I have never heard of
ineluctably.
*unexpected thump*
Ah. Okay, thumpy thump win for me, huh?
Oh.
Ah.
Hi?
Uh?
*another unexpected thump*
O-Oh.
Ohh.
Oh.
Okay.
OK. Oh, I'm moving.
Alrighty then. Welp yep.
Wander right into Emporium.
This seems like a good idea.
OK.
I don't know why I'm going in here, but alright.
*thumping becomes more intense*
Did I just fall from the roof?
Why was I lying- bloody- in the middle of the Rooa-
-OK hi.
What the Hell is this?
My God.
This is so crazy.
Look at this place- Oh hi there!
Can you help me understand what the Hell is going on here,
because I seem to be missing something here.
Hey, buddy. How's it going? How are you doing?
The boy did nothing, just looked up at me.
There was a flicker of recognition,
and I felt like a time traveler.
He seemed unsure of what to say next."
I met my father only once, or my mother raised me poorly?!
Aahh! I don't know!
I don't know!
Is this important?! I don't know!
I met my father only once!
He spoke rapidly now, fantasy stories of super hero dads.
*fwooooooooooosh*
I don't think that's what I meant.
I knew them to be mostly untrue.
But choose- chose to believe, regardless.
OK.
I don't know if I want to go in that trailer, sir.
I don't know if that's- alright. You know what I'm going to go in anyway.
Oh my Gahd.
This game is so-o weird,
and I love it.
Like I LOVE it.
It's weird, but it's cool.
I am shipwrecked this morning.
Folded over into sorry waves.
Water, water, everywhere.
Oh.
Why am I here?! What?!
The RV was just a piece of cardboard.
Ohh, OK.
I'm folded out onto the waves of the ocean! Where suddenly we're playing Raft again.
Oh. Do I need to declare my loneliness to the world?
Oh, boy.
Oh boy.
Oh, bo- oh, hi. There you are.
I didn't even see you there.
I found myself busy. It whispers with some kind of ocean.
I didn't notice the boy by my side, staring out, counting the waves.
In a rushed fluster, the boy tugged my sleeve, and beckoned my ear closer.
*ghastly exhale*
A child is only a child once, or I'd like to try and drown.
Ahhh. I wouldn't like to try that.
That's like one of my worse ways I could possibly die.
I'll go with, a child is only a child once, thank you.
The boy spoke of a newly hatched egg.
Did I?!
The babe featherless. Breathless and still.
Lost in some rotten tumble.
Whoa.
The guy that made the visuals on this are really really cool.
Ah.
I don't know what else you want from me.
Okay.
I guess I'll.. go back?
Can I go back now?
La da dee doo doo doo-
Ooooooooooooo
Kay.
That's a..
That's a big building! (x1)
That's a big building! (x2)
That's a big building! (x3)
That is a big building! (x4)
Eh, it popped up out of nowhere!
It's a big building!
O-Oh... Hi.
Okay, climby climb we go!
I don't know why we're here and I don't know who put it here.
Ooh..
It's uncomfortable..
Oh, hi.
Okay, hello.
Someone in there?
Why would someone be in there?
Oh, hi.
Oh... Don't look at me like that.
Oh, don't do that to me.
Ohh-Don't look at me like that.!
I was left in the company of my father for a single day.
I don't believe he spoke at all.
He just walked along that peer and held my hand while I toddled in tow.
The impossible depth of that green grey water is all I remember clearly.
So that has to do with the choice I made in the beginning of the game.
I think.
I'm pretty sure that would've changed.
I don't know if this has multiple endings to this, I have no idea.
I don't know the ramifications of these decisions.
But, I'm sooooo curious.
And also not curious because i'm not sure I wanna know where this is leading me to.
Higher and higher I go in this tower in the middle of nowhere.
Through halls that I can't control.
Oh.. Ah, Okay I'm back here but now there's a bird house!
I think I understand the analogy of that!
FLY FREE pretty little birdy!
Oh boy.
Wait, are we just starting over again?
Do I have to make all the choices?
Do I have to make the *right* choices here?
I don't know!!
I'm not sure!
What's with the bird house?!
Ookkaayy.
Why is there an emporium?
Hello birdy birdy.
The nesting box was no longer a home.
I placed it here so the boy could listen for himself.
That never ending, inconsolable cry.
Emanating from such a tiny hole, powered by impossible acoustics.
Okay, alright, good reminder! Thank you for that, I think.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
If we go in here and I have to make different choices I'll do that but I do-
Ookay.
Ah.
This is different.
That wasn't a trolley car there and there was no kitchen over there.
I have no idea what this is..
Was I supposed to be looking at-
Oh
Hi.
Ohhhhhh.
The plaque read "Hiding place No. 08,"
Or "Dinner with Mother."
Ohh.
Oh.
That's sad..
I didn't know that these were exhibits that I was supposed to look at.
The plaque read "Hiding place No. 143,"
Or,
"Stationary."
Hundred forty-three?!
How many hiding places do you need?!
Why do you need so many hiding spaces?
What is happening?
The plaque read "Hiding place No. 00,"
Eugh, alrighty then. Well I can't go-
Ooo
Kay.
Alright, oh the camera is going fuckey on me.
The plaque read "Hiding place No. 06,"
Or,
"Wooden Masks"
Fascinating.
Okay, so I'm going to talk to the guy but this is definitely different right?
I'm not crazy here.
It's different.
I think.
I don't know.
I tried to remember what it was like to be young.
Perhaps the boy would remind me.
Perhaps it would make a difference.
Oh.
I can think myself invisible.
Being alone is part of survival.
I kinda disagree with one of those, but I don't think I can think myself invisible
But that like, relates to all the hiding places, I guess.
Kind of? In a way?
The boy's voice deepened now. He spoke slow, low, and quiet.
His words came from me as if from inside my own chest.
And as they did, I swear I saw him blur around the edges.
Okay. That's weird. Yeah, okay, I'll step into your weird RV home.
I'm sure nothing horrible is gonna happen.
Am I gonna awaken on a pier again or am I gonna go somewhere else?
I had a heady notion to flee.
The sensation had come fast, and I found it intoxicating.
I needed to vanish.
And have the void left in my wake shrink up behind me.
Oh, this is different.
Oh.
Ah.
Okay. Well, there's the trolley car.
What is all of this?
Oh, man. It's so weird. I've never really seen a game told from this perspective before.
Just let alone the isometric view of it, but like, from such a distant shot, too. Like it's really, really cool.
Oops, almost missed my target there. Dur-di-durski!
Oh man, what the hell happened over there?
I mean, I know none of this is actual reality here, but...
Oh, boy.
"I once lent on this bridge, ready to take myself over its barrier.
"Hoping for one of the ancient locomotives to rattle forth and run me through." Ugh!
"I waited a lifetime before I realized  all the trains had stopped running.
"It was in this waiting that I first met the boy."
Oh.
"Anything can crumble in an instant," or "To be still is to be peaceful."
That sounds moderately pleasant.
I guess.
But also I kinda believe this one. Anything *can* crumble in an instant.
I don't know! I'll go with the peaceful one!
"The boy regaled me with our travels and commutes.
"That kinetic score of steam and metal...
"How we wished for silence.
"To be grave and static."
Oh wait, unless you meant, like, to be still is- okay, that's all right then.
Alrighty then. I'll be on my way. Unless you meant to be still is to be peaceful, as in...
...death.
'Cause that's not as nice as I might have thought that it would be.
Anything can crumble in an instant, just the same as any trains can just fly off into  the sky.
And then be lost to the void!
I have no idea what's happening.
Okay, further up we go, I guess! Unless this is the exact same way to go, and then, honestly, who knows.
Jeez.
Hello. Hi.
Do you have some mysteries to unfold for me?
Oh, don't look at me like that. I still don't like it.
Just compared to the last one, I don't think I'll like it.
"I have a superpower that no one else knows about.
"I discovered this when I was 6 years old." Is it to be invisible?
"I would let my breathing shallow and keep myself perfectly still.
"Before I knew it, I would fade into something almost like water.
"And seep through every crack in the earth."
I don't know what that means, and I don't know how useful that superpower is. That seems...
Seems weird, and uh... metaphorical, even.
Oh! We're still going up!
We didn't get sent out into the abyss!
Okay. Unless I didn't get sent out into the abyss before. I don't remember.
I can't remember!
Are we going back? Are we gonna go back? Do we have to go back?
I don't know!
I don't know any- Oh, we're back now.
Oh, good! Ah, yes, we have a new exhibit.
Is there gonna be something poetic about that one, too?
God, it seems like if I had to guess what's going on here, this guy is looping through his life after he...
...threw himself from the roof of this building.
Whatever this building is. Like that splotch of blood on the ground is where he landed.
"I had built a shrine to monotony.
"There is a calm to be found in repetition." Heh!
"So I would busy myself in dizzy little circles until sick from the spin."
Great. Is that like an easter egg? Am I supposed to dizzy myself in sweet circles until I'm sick from the spin?
Because I can do that. (laughing) Here I go!
(uncomfortable laughing) Whee-hee-hee-hee! Whoo-hoo!
Aah, fun!
All right. Gonna give it one more loop and then I'm out of here!
Ah... All right. I'm gone.
Whoosh. Whooshki.
Here we are, back in the lovely emporium! The building of epic proportions.
Okay. So the kitchen is the same, this is different, and that exhibit up there is different.
"The plaque reads 'Hiding Place  No. 56' or 'Head Office.'"
Right. I don't know where the head office is located.
Ugh.
Hello. How are you doing?
Ugh. "The plaque reads 'Hiding Place No. 23' or 'Mr. Invisible.'"
Not very invi- I see you. Sorry to burst your bubble.
Sorry to burst anything here.
Hello? You want to talk to me again? Give me some more choices that I don't understand?
"The boy looked ready for battle." Do I?
"His eyes darted, holding only to still me with a vicious glare.
"Pursed and tense, the boy seemed violent like never before.
"We can live forever," or "Are we going to die?"
One's not true.
"Are we going to die?"
Ooh, ugh...
"The boy cried loud and angry.
"I could offer no comfort or reason.
"We are unfortunates without escape."
Okay. All right.
Whatever you say.
I'll go on my way now.
Agh!
What's happening?
I don't know!
I'm trying to make sense of this!
"Every horrid click and clack is tattooed across my body
"Every smell runs thick as oil down my arms and fingers.
"I am poisoned by industry and at mercy to that bend of fleshy iron."
I don't know where I am now. This doesn't seem like bending fleshy iron.
Okay.
Ah! Nice chair. Ohh!
You're talking about slaving away your life in cubicles!
Ah, a maze!
Ah!
Okay...
I don't get it.
Oh, boy.
I mean, I do get it. I'm not saying I'm completely lost here. I do get it.
It's like a categorical of this guy's life. I wouldn't be surprised if this old man turned out to be this boy.
"This is ridicule, I told the boy.
"This errant machine requires constant attention.
"No more will we mend and maintain.
"Let it turn to rust. The bones will scatter under their own weight."
"Let it carry you," or "Abandon everything."
Well, that seems pretty grim.
I'm gonna go with the no-quite-so-positive-but-possibly-more-meaningful "let it carry you"?
"The boy heard it, too.
"That melodic automation of gears and guts.
"He urged me to engage.
"To find peace in that rhythmic human whisper."
Okay.
Oh hi, hi, hello, hi, you're a long- you're a long boy
Okay, alright then I'm gonna enter the tip here I guess
Nothing.. What about this one?
Ah
Okay
I-
Ugh
Okay back up we're going I guess, I'm going up and there we go
See, there are like some other outcomes to this if you pick different choices
Do they all lead to the same place or do they all have branching paths?
Do they all infect the story in different ways?
I don't know
Why are you in that room alone, why are you sitting-
What does it mean?
"I am tired now"
"I feel this body built around me expanding"
"Before long I'm sure I won't be able to see the walls of it"
"And I will echo into silence"
Wow, okay
Okay
Alrighty then
Thank you
Alright I'm gonna go up now
I don't know how many loops I'm supposed to make here
It's all just obscure poetry at this point
with some deeper meaning hidden in
I know, I know there's a deeper meaning hidden here
or maybe it's pretty blatant on its surface
Oh there I am again
There I am again
Oh, what is that?
Is that an iron lung?
What does that mean?
Iron lung is like a horrifying.. device that helped people breathe
"This was a gift from the boy to me"
"A breath"
"A life"
"Inevitably I chose to ignore it"
Yep.. That's an iron lung
I don't know why there's an iron lung there
I'm not hundred percent sure why anything's here
And I really hope I don't have to fill every parking space on this bad boy
because that will take a- Oh
It's empty
Why is it empty?
Where'd he go? Okay I miss him now
Where'd he go?
Where did he go??
*Scary music plays*
Where did he go ?
I don't know
My life was built brittle as if wouldn't a simple toy
without a full set what remains will fragment
perfect perfect perfect perfect
perfect little perfect perfect little perfect
oh okay I don't know what this is
hello I'm here now
I will go upstairs I think
mother is yhat you up there
oh
The boy  searched for me without luck
he did however find where I was keeping her
A wife in ruin and mother to a ghost
he spoke aloud knowing I would hear
She is strong or you were weak
I'm gonna go with you were strong
she's strong
my wife's perseverance was enough to
bring us both through
she became mother-like to me
why did I resent this
no not resentment I was a burden
a parasite held in embrace
that's sad
I don't know if that's true hey wait don't close on me
don't close on me
oh hi we're floating now apparently or we're falling now apparently
oh I can't control this
Oh No gentle caress huh
okay I have no idea where I am now
is this what we might call the afterlife oh
my god that's so weird
oh man it was weird
oh there I go okay I thought I was gonna
okay there we go
okay we're fine
everything's fine I'm just gonna go get my balloon
okay
Oh don't
don't
No
Okay I thought he was gonna throw himself from the top of the stairs
oh no no no no no you don't
oh don't give me with that mannequin shit
don't do that don't do that
oh man okay I think like the old man might be the father
and why are there so many mom
mannequins
mom-equins
why there's so many of them
hello mama
nothing explain anything to me
No? Okay I'll just head inside, mom
thanks
thanks mama
thank you for that
oh boy
oh shit it's the hiding places finally opened up
oh and there's a lovely cloud duvet in the back
good for me I suppose
oh where am I now
oh no don't
Oh No I got a bad feeling about this one
this one seems
oh okay got a bad feeling about this one
Oh No oh no
I think I know what's about
to happen
oh I think I know what's about to happen
oh don't do it
don't do it
Oh No
Ho no
okay
not so bad
oh no no
Oh No Oh No
I'm like marching towards the precipice
as if it's the only option but obviously
it is, there's nothing else there
He's not getting up this time
The Emporium seemed most fitting
Nearby retail expansions had left both my business and the building derelict
I'd often take my lunch on the roof during slow and sunny days
A quiet spot where no one would notice me
Yes, the Emporium seems most fitting
I let my fingers and feet go numb
as I wished the boy farewell
*heavy sigh* I think...
Oh...
I think the story is more apparent
towards the ending there...
it's, at its heart it's about someone
running away and trying to hide
Like, talking about the boy
as if the boy was a different person
An old man probably being the father
It's obvious there's not different endings to that one
That is a --
That's a "mess you up" kinda game
Anyway
Whenever I play a game like this
that touches on a very serious subject,
I always want to make sure at the end of it
that I remind you guys that
Suicide is never the answer
It's... you know, there's as many cliches as you could say about it as you want but...
It's...
It's awful
I'm not intending to take this time to be
as profound as I could be... or try to be
But in this moment,
it's something to remember:
that if you are ever thinking of taking your own life,
there are people that want to help you
and there's people that want to know you
and there's people that want to be there for you
And I think it's a really, really important thing
that we've touched on before
For subjects of depression,
subjects of suicide where
it's just heartbreaking
and I would actively encourage
anyone that is having dark thoughts, or
going through rough times,
to reach out and seek help
Not only just in this community alone and
there are many resources in here
but there's also resources out there --
We've done charity events for
the depression and bipolar support alliance
and crisis text line
and various different charities for this but...
just from one person to another
I would ask you to hold on
and stay strong and keep fighting
whatever the demons that you're fighting
and I can't know them
because I haven't experienced them
in the way that you have
but that's all I ask:
is that you stay strong and reach out
So anyway, I'll leave it at that
I know I don't want to come across as preachy
especially when it comes to something like this
but that's the long and short of it so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Reach out to someone, down in the comments below
Reach out to someone else in the community or somewhere else
and then reach out to those resources
that I talked about
and there's even more and I'm sure
people can list more down in the comments below so
thank you everybody so much for watching,
thank you to the creator of this game
and as always:
I will see you in the next video, bye bye!